jean frédéric poisson le député de la
10e circonscription des yvelines est
l'invité politique de ce soir on change
de sujet on va parler du duel françois
fillon jean françois copé vous avez
décidé de soutenir jean françois copé
l'actuel secrétaire général de l'ump
élections prévues le 18 novembre pour
les adhérents de ce mouvement
pourquoi ce choix de jean françois copé
pour trois raisons la première c'est que
j'ai été membre du groupe ump dans la
mandature précédente je les ai vus
diriger le groupe politique notre groupe
politique à l'assemblée nationale je les
veux diriger comme secrétaire national
de l'ump que je suis encore notre
famille politique et il a montré dans
ces deux circonstances
des qualités qui sont essentiels à mon
avis pour diriger ce genre
d'organisation deuxièmement c'est un
point de vue un peu plus humain mais ça
compte pour moi en tout cas
lorsque j'ai perdu les élections
législatives de juillet 2010 mon
téléphone a sonné un peu moins j'avais
un bon carnet d adresses c'est un petit
peu c'est un petit peu amaigri et jean
françois a fait partie des personnes qui
constamment m'ont apporté leur soutien
leur présence leur fidélité et cela
restera positive en politique je pense
que la loyauté la fidélité ça doit
pouvoir exister aussi et je pratique
volontiers jette volontiers ce qui monte
mais un jour troisièmement je pense
qu'il a envie de faire ce métier là si
je peux appeler ça un métier il peut y
avoir des ambitions nationales bien sûr
et françois fillon évidemment les
qualités pour être un bon candidat à la
primaire 2017 mais ça n'est pas le sujet
que nous avons à traiter aujourd'hui
lorsque vous faites ça choix justement
de jean françois copé vous vous projetez
pour qui ces morts c'est en 2010 est non
ce n'est pas ce qui nous est demandé ce
n'est pas le choix que je fais je ne
présume pas de ce que sera l'attitude
que j'adopterai dans cinq ans quand il
faudra désigner notre candidat à la
primaire pour la présidentielle si
jamais nous avons un candidat désigné
dans une primaire
moi je regarde l'occupation le travail
que va devoir faire celui qui sera à la
tête de notre famille politique pendant
les trois ans qui viennent trois ans pas
cinquante trois ans et ce travail là je
pense jean-françois copé a envie de le
faire il a envie de le faire d'une
manière qui me convient donc pour ces
trois raisons je le soutiens la campagne
est ce que vous la trouvez difficile
dure entre les deux candidats françois
jean françois copé alors elle est moins
raide que ce que je craignais pour tout
vous dire notamment entre les deux
candidats eux-mêmes en général dans ces
circonstances assez costaud l'entourent
c'est exactement ça que j'ai rien vous
dire s'il ya quand même des ya quand
même des jets de boulons et de vices et
de clous un petit peu je pense surtout
que c'est très long pour tout vous dire
nous avons une tâche d'opposition
abonnés maintenant notamment au
parlement
mais pâques ou parlement nous passons
beaucoup de temps à ce scrutin en
interne nous passons beaucoup de temps
dans nos réunions à travailler sur les
modalités et c'est trop à mon avis donc
il est temps que ça se termine
et ça pénalise l'action de l'opposition
à celle de ray allen bien sûr ça nous
prend de l'énergie et du temps ce qui
est normal puisque une campagne
électorale se fait pas non plus en
claquant des doigts et en restant assis
dans son fauteuil donc ça mobilise des
gens c'est un vrai affrontement je pense
qu'il est loyal et qu'il est viril mais
correct commander rugby donc voilà je
pense que d'ailleurs salué le sentiment
que nos militants et nos sympathisants
c'est que le climat n'est pas délétère
au point qu'on puisse craindre une
fracture lendemain enfin j'ai eu beau
entendu beaucoup de choses là dessus ça
n'arrivera pas de toute façon puis nous
y allons c'est impossible de se réunir
dans des faudra il le faudra quel que
soit le candidat qui gagnera 18 le 19 au
matin je serai derrière le président élu
et je trace rsa faire de ces rencontres
il faudra attendre la basse et un
deuxième tour avec deux candidats c'est
un peu difficile à imaginer mais
faudrait qu'ils viennent voter oui il
doit y avoir un quorum mais j'en suis
même pas certain d'ailleurs vous
m'invitez à regarder mais ce statut que
je ne connais pas bien voyez vous avez
respectivement ça sera l'occasion de
revenir
et justement ses adhérents vous les
sentez mobilisés pour participer à cette
élection où il disait opinions publiques
au niveau des sondages niveau national
adhérent ou non en tout cas plutôt les
non adhérents sens pas très passionnée
par mon message je comprends très bien
de la même façon que l'opinion n'était
pas non plus passionnés par l'élection
du premier secrétaire du ps ya quelques
années à reims et qu'il n'est pas
davantage par la nomination de monsieur
désiré quelques semaines donc ce sont
des affections d'affaires de famille
d'une certaine façon mais d'une famille
un peu particulière puisque ces familles
sont censés représenter l'opinion
publique maintenant que ça ne passionne
pas les foules
je le comprends très bien
ça passionne pas non plus tous les
militants certains d'entre eux une
partie raisonnable sont intéressés ma
foi normalement compte tenu des
circonstances mais ça ne provoque
d'enthousiastes nulle part ça je dois à
la vérité de dire je vous propose
d'écouter à présent valérie pécresse et
la chef de file de l'ump dans le
département elle a choisi de soutenir
françois fillon on l'écouté on verra si
elle a réussi à vous convaincre pour
conclure valérie pécresse nous vous
retrouvons ici à l'assemblée nationale
ma première question sera de vous
demander quels soutiens quel candidat
vous soutenez justement dans cette
présidence à l'ump
alors je soutiens françois fillon c'est
un choix que j'ai fait en conviction
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le meilleur pour incarner l'opposition à
françois hollande est le meilleur pour
faire gagner l'ump
alors on connaît la position du député
de la 10e circonscription des yvelines
jean frédéric poisson qui lui soutient
plutôt jean françois copé quel est votre
regard par rapport à ce soutien
mais je crois que nous sommes dans la
même famille politique et que donc
chacun d'entre nous libre de ses choix
moi c'est un choix que j'ai fait en
conscience parce que françois fillon
pour moi la stature d'un homme d'état
pendant cinq ans il a été aux côtés de
nicolas sarkozy sont plus proches
soutiens politiques
il a était à l'origine des plus grandes
réformes que la france ait connu depuis
dix ans il incarne pour moi à la fois la
vérité
il a dit que la france était en faillite
le courage il m'a aidé dans ma réforme
des universités et l'esprit républicain
puisque vous savez que c'est aussi lui
qui était à l'origine de la loi
interdisant le voile à l'école
donc vous êtes vous resté pour un choix
individuel pour le soutient la
candidature
la présidence de l'ump parce que les ce
que les militants ump doivent comprendre
c'est qu'en n'élisant fillon il met
liront aussi il met liront secrétaire
général de l'ump et que à ce titre comme
secrétaire général
moi je veux mener une vraie révolution
démocratique au sein du parti et je veux
mettre les militants au coeur du
fonctionnement l'ump je veux que leur
carte d'adhérent devienne un bulletin de
vote qu'on les consulte par référendum à
la fois sur les idées du parti sur les
méthodes de fonctionnement du parti
je veux mieux les former je veux que
l'ump deviennent vraiment un outil au
service de la reconquête de nos
territoires
frédéric poisson votre réaction à ce
qu'elle respecte reste vous a convaincu
non d'abord je n'embrasse vous vivez là
bas c'est une bonne introduction
voilà non mais enfin vous voyez que ce
débat ce ce débat se déroule dans des
dans les termes qui sont quand même
extrêmement courtois il manquerait plus
que ça d'ailleurs
il peut y avoir des explications
familiale un peu sèche parfois mais ça
reste dans des proportions tout à fait
normal voilà je crois que nous avons la
chance d'avoir deux très bons candidats
c'est d'ailleurs d'autres difficultés
c'est en même temps d'autres forces nous
en sortirons bien quoi qu'il arrive le
18 novembre au soir
en toute hypothèse incertaine et en tout
cas pas ce qui vous avez en tout cas
était impartial mais au niveau des deux
candidats affrontera fillon jean
françois copé si françois fillon est élu
puisque les sondages le donnent et je
suis en avance mais je suis sûr que
l'association les amis qui soutiennent
françois fillon sont exactement dans le
même attitude et seront derrière jean
françois copé le 19 au matin
merci d'être venus des plateaux ont
commenté donc cette actualité ce duel en
jean françois copé et françois fillon le
7-8 remis un demain vendredi avec 4
résulats tôt pour l'édition du week-end
je vous retrouve lundi en direct avec de
nouveaux invités excellente soirée
n'oubliez pas notre site internet pour
revoir tous nos reportages et les
réseaux sociaux pour les commenter